oh say I said it right there I was like
there's like I was like you a woman I'm
a man can there's a different tow what
they bump [ __ ] up in here here it is
it's going on
go which one
a young [ __ ] [ __ ] me I did [ __ ]
you gonna do a fine
well
Oh babbit bubble-brain oh yeah yeah what
you left with my friends go to me you
lucky cuz I'll take your head off
don't hold me back doc don't huh me back
okay don't worry
see I know though if I were to lunge at
you right now my friend right here he
cast me at the last possible second no
no no I won't
but my friend does have the cognizance
to tell me I don't need to be going up
and committing capital murder
I've gonna club tonight just knock him
unconscious dog hey don't kill anybody
don't need that success
I will I will
oh you know what you lucky my boys using
his telekinetic powers to hold me back
right now
no I'm not well maybe it's the type of
telekinesis power you had over here it's
like a little baby he can't get past me
like a little out what what you I'm a
little baby I got carried away I
apologize carried away you told me hold
you back holding you back wouldn't let
me to go in a fight situation no means
no and yes oh come on man come on that
hurt and you holding me back now thank
you very much for that okay we'll just
have these change it up okay now you
listen
you